hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
most of the time
you'll see a big difference if weather
is reported in fahrenheit or in celsius
usually the temperature in fahrenheit is
substantially larger than the same
temperature expressed in celsius
but there are certain cities and extreme
weather conditions in which the
fahrenheit and celsius values are nearly
the same number so this raises an
interesting mathematical question about
these two temperature scales
at what temperature does the degrees in
fahrenheit exactly equal the degrees in
celsius
we'll start with the conversion that the
degrees in fahrenheit is equal to
nine-fifths times the degrees in celsius
plus 32.
we want the degrees in fahrenheit to
equal the degrees in celsius
so we'll write degrees celsius for
degrees fahrenheit
we now have an equation in one variable
we'll write five over five for one
we now subtract nine fifths degrees
celsius from both sides
we then multiply both sides by negative
five over four
and we get the answer of negative 40
degrees celsius is exactly equal to
negative 40 degrees fahrenheit
if you are in such conditions like parts
of the united states right now please
stay warm
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over a
hundred million views and the channel
has over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check my merchandise on
teespring you can check out my books
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support